Bo Peep has a secret actually she has a
lot of Secrets but we're about to find
out what they are when lamp life a new
toy story short hits Disney Plus later
this month lamp life will explore the
events between Toy Story 2 and 4 when Bo
Peep was given away and had to strike
out on her own
so what kind of adventures did Bo have
that led to her becoming a lost toy and
what events caused her to literally
catch on fire during her time away
here's everything we know so far
[Music]
Toy Story has explored the lives of a
lot of different toys who come to life
when their kids aren't watching the
latest film really highlighted the life
of Bo Peep and her development as a
character but there's still a lot of
mystery about how she got to where she
is Little Bo Peep isn't featured in
2010's Toy Story 3 and that's because
she was one of the many toys that was
given away over the years as Andy and
Molly grew up but Bo peeps always had a
close relationship with Andy's other
toys especially woody who was her love
interest in the second film however the
fourth film finds her living a life as a
lost toy she makes her home in a park
and drives around in an RC car disguised
as a skunk to keep the people away her
closest friends are her little sheep
sidekicks choice story for gave us a
little glimpse into her life before she
found herself lost but lamp life will be
focusing on all of the crazy adventures
she got herself into before deciding
that the life of a lost toy was the
perfect life for her but we've spent
most of her life as a decoration on a
lamp this means that she spent most of
her time standing around playing
lullabies and shining light for her kid
Molly she definitely enjoyed the life of
helping Molly sleep and protecting her
from the darkness but Toy Story 4 showed
us all that Bo Peep has an adventurous
side she seems so at home as a lost toy
living in the park with no kid telling
her what to do but not having a home
definitely has its downsides
especially for a toy who exists to bring
joy to children without a kid what's
Bo's purpose Bo Peep introduces her
story by saying that life on a baby lamp
isn't so exciting but she quickly back
tracks and says that sometimes it's
actually too exciting in the trailer she
is set on fire frozen and snow fights
stray cats and survives what looks like
a pretty crazy college party how did she
get into all of these crazy situations
it's safe to say that Bo Peep has been a
lot of places between Toy Story 2 and 4
we even get another glimpse at those
creepy Benson dolls that were the most
disturbing part of Toy Story 4 between
escaping dolls breaking one of her
porcelain arms and going through a
complete wardrobe change both seen and
done a lot of things before she finally
reunites with woody she struggled with
loneliness not being wanted by a new
child and adapting to a life as a
runaway where sure she has a lot to
share with woody about these crazy times
but the most important question is after
all the changes in growth she's
experienced is Bo Peep happy with how
things turned out Bo Peep story will be
told as a narration from Bo de woody as
they hang out on a carnival
rollercoaster so we can expect some very
personal stories about her fun and
emotional experiences as an unwanted toy
what we know about those life so far is
that when she was accidentally given
away she spent a couple of years sitting
on a shelf in an antique store and then
she spent some time as a toy to a kid
who didn't really want her this all
sounds pretty tragic for Bo but the
Shepherd is proved in Toy Story 4 that
she can roll with the punches with her
flock and woody by her side we're going
to find out everything Bo has learned
about herself during her daring
adventures as a renegade we know that
Tom Hanks will return as the voice of
woody along with Annie Potts is the
voice of Little Bo Peep we can probably
expect some other fun cameos from more
of our favorite Toy Story characters the
short will officially launch on Disney
Plus on January 31st and will be
followed in February by the release of
Toy Story 4 on the streaming platform
all other Toy Story films and shorts are
already available on the service so
February is shaping up to be a month
dedicated to all our favorite toys
so what are you hoping to learn about Bo
Peep in the new short let us know in the
comments and thanks for watching
don't forget to like this video and
subscribe for more
[Music]